hello everyone and welcome to a most
incredible game uh from round four of
the ftx crypto cup uh it is pragnanda
versus levon arunyan uh and it is uh
quite an incredible game the game
basically ends uh in 10 moves so you
guys will really know that one it gets
dragged out a little bit as it's always
hard to resign in such situations uh but
um basically it does end on move 10 so
can pragnanda continue in this
incredible style he already won his
previous three matches and now he faces
the legendary levon arunyan this is the
third game of their match like i
mentioned uh first game was a very it
was a fighting draw a second game was an
incredibly fighting royal levon had a
win with the white pieces it was a
really wild game so do check it out if
you get the chance but this game uh this
is something else entirely so let's
check it out uh prague has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 by levon uh c for g6
knights to c3 and d5 levon goes for the
groomfield defense and here prague goes
knight to f3 the three knights variation
of the groomfield bishop to g7 and now c
captures on d5 knight captures and now
e4 chasing away the knight knight
captures b captures and now pawn to c5
levon strikes uh against prague's center
and usually when we have this position
on the board i always mention that there
are four moves that are basically always
played here uh the the top moves being
uh
rook to b1 uh let's say bishop to c4
bishop to e3 and all bishop to e2 there
are some games where it was played those
are basically the four uh most popular
moves but here rock plays a ponte h3 it
is the fifth most popular move and uh it
is uh
it's not uh played all that much but it
has been played in one game magnus
carlsen played against janipanishi in
the 2020s killing open that ended in a
draw uh in case you were wondering and
okay here are levon castles we have
bishop to e3 and now queen to a5 so the
one playing standard grunfeldian moves
that are always very very much useful
and now prague goes back bishop to d2 as
the the c3 pawn is now attacked so
bishop back to d2 even though you could
play uh queen to d2 bishop to d2 seems
like such a loss of a tempo
but he manages to completely trick levon
and here lebron should uh uh oh well his
spidey sense should definitely go off
and he should uh you know be sounding uh
be hearing the alarm sounding uh and he
should play something like queen to a3
or go back or play knight the c6 or
bishop to d7 but most certainly not the
move he played and that is pawn to b6
and now if you look at the position uh
look at the black queen on a5 look at
the b6 pawn completely blocking the
queen's retreat the c7 or d8 the light
square bishop slicing over the light of
course the dark square bishop uh well
x-raying those dark squares the queen
controlling these light squares so what
is the black queen to play they're still
the a3 square well not really because
here proc plays queen to b3 takes away
the a3 square from the black queen he
could have played a4 right away uh but
okay levon plays bishop to d7 and now
pawn to a4 taking the a4 square away
from the black queen and there really
isn't a good move for lavon here this is
uh just um
well completely unplayable what you
could can do here is maybe try and give
up a pawn with b5 and then try and play
the same game but this is just uh
silly for example bishop characters and
b5 bishop characters queen captures and
your position is terrible you're down
upon and white has this massive center
that white usually has against the
groomfield uh this would be well with uh
you know
with uh decent play this would be a win
for white so instead levon tries to keep
on to everything he plays pawn to e6 but
now uh a beautiful beautiful move by
prague a brilliancy if you will rook to
a2 rook to 82 with the very concrete
idea of the rook not hanging on a1 after
the position opens up because the queen
can capture the rook on a1 if the pawn
disappears and now there really is no
good way of countering this bishop to b5
idea uh if you play bishop to b5 right
away then you can't play pawn captures
because the rook would hang on a1 so now
with the rogue being on a2 bishop to b5
is truly a terrible threat your real
idea
for example a bishop the c6 was played
by levon and now your real idea is c4
and this will win the queen however if
you play c4 right away the bishop no
longer controls um these squares and you
can move the queen so that's uh the the
real reason uh so here we have bishop to
b5 by prague and now there is no defense
against pawn to c4 that's the the beauty
of it uh and of course now bishop
captures runs into eight captures and
the queen is again trapped that's why
the rook had to move from a1 rook to a2
such a classy move by prong so after
bishop to b5 elevon tries
to wiggle out of this but it really
doesn't work c4 now he does give up a
pawn queen captures on c for rook the c8
but probably just goes back queen to b3
there will be no saving the black queen
this game with ponta a6 at least um
lebron will grab the bishop pair for the
queen but now pawn to c4 and that's
really all there is to it uh a captus
and b5 level one has to give up the
queen bishop captures on a5 b captures
on c4 now but even queen captures on c4
there are no useful discoveries against
the white queen so b characters on a5
and now probably just calmly castles as
like we said there are no useful
discoveries and now usually you would
resign this but as this is a match
format and lavone uh well
maybe he can manage something maybe
maybe he can drag and drag it out get a
draw or something he will of course try
to play this night day six queen to e2
we have knight to b4 and now rook a to
a1 uh we have bishop back to e8 and now
rook f the c one now probably just has
to trade as he is up material so real
captures where row captures now comes
bishop captures on a4 which is
incredible if uh
levon can get the bishop out of the way
and maybe start pushing the pass pawn
but now comes knight to e5
we have bishop back to e8 now hoping to
start pushing the past pawn but now
queen to c4 now you can't push because
the knight hangs so pawn to h6 and now
queen to c7 now here prague is going
after the rook on a8 we have bishop to
f8 now defending the knight hoping to
start pushing the pass pawn but now
queen b7 prague just doesn't give levon
any time to do this rook to d8 and now
rook uh the c8 trading off the the pair
of rocks as without the rook it will be
incredibly difficult to escort this pawn
down the board you could also do it with
the bishop pair if you guys remember i
believe it's uh game six of the match
fischer larson from the candidates 1971
uh how fisher nicely escorted the
passport with the with the bishop perry
after giving up his queen
but this isn't um
quite such a position so rook captures
uh on c8 queen characters on c8 now
comes bishop to a4 as the bishop is
hanging here but now prague very
elegantly plays queen to c7 attacks the
a5 pawn and there is no defending the
pawn so bishop to e8 we have queen
captures on a5 knights the c6 and knight
captures and c6 with bishop captures and
d5 and he was in this position almost 34
that levon arunyan resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
here after the trade
of course prague gets a pass pawn and
there's no good move you can make once
you move the bishop just queen c7 and we
escorted the pawn up the board there is
no stopping this even though he still
has the bishop pair uh so an incredibly
incredible game by by prague but
basically the game ended uh on move 10
when lebron played b6 uh as their
there's really no way
you can play this queen b3 followed by
a4 or even the immediate a4 uh keeps the
queen there on the a5 square uh proc saw
this and uh for some reason
uh levon uh either messed up his
preparation or uh basically i i don't
think maybe it was messing up the
progression i just uh think his spidey
sense didn't go off
uh
that's the game incredible win by
pragnanda in round three of the ftx
crypto cup against lavon arunian if he
manages to get a draw in the fourth game
or a win then he will have won his
fourth match in a row which is
absolutely incredible and if you guys
are wondering it's uh the last round of
the tournament that prague will face
magnus carlsen
so uh you know the the tension is
definitely building up but uh again huge
huge congratulations on this win uh
because even though b6 is a positional
uh mistake you know prague really took
advantage of it and
created a brilliancy
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it always you know take care of
your positions and uh you know
attend to your spidey sense so it always
tingles
i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to jonathan lottie and i would
like to thank brandon ward johan claus
on raymond raphael and boontyakpung for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions but basically
uh covering the ftx crypto cup until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day